[Musik]
und jetzt das heute schon mit gundula
gause und bettina schausten
guten abend an einem tag der geprägt war
von der zeitenwende in der wir stehen
die ukraine stemmt sich gegen den
aufmarsch russischer truppen im osten
was dafür an waffen nötig ist darüber
geht hier bei uns die diskussion weiter
genauso wie die aufarbeitung was im
verhältnis zu russland in den letzten
jahren schief lief verantwortung wird
neu definiert
heute auch bei der linken deren
vorsitzende hinwarf über all das bringen
wir sie jetzt auf den neuesten stand und
beginnen in mario pohl wo einem
kommandeur der ukrainischen verteidiger
der horror des krieges ins gesicht
geschrieben steht ulrike rolle berichtet
die lage sei grauenvoll sagt der
stellvertretende bürgermeister von mario
pohl über seine stadt die meisten
gebäude zerstört ein leben dort fast
nicht mehr möglich
in diesem stahlwerk soll noch etwa 2500
ukrainische soldaten seien sie wollen
nicht aufgeben heute nun meldet sich von
dort ein ukrainischer kommandeur zu wort
seine botschaft verzweifelt
das ist unser appell an die welt es kann
der letzte unseres lebens sein wir haben
wahrscheinlich nur noch wenige tage wenn
nicht stunden zum überleben der feind
ist uns überlegen in einem verhältnis 10
zu 1 bitte helfen sie uns heraus zu
kommen und bringen sie uns in einem
drittstaat
passiert ist bis zum abend nichts das
ultimatum verstrich
der ukrainischen regierung gelang es
heute einen flucht korridor für mario
pohl auszuhandeln 90 busse sollten es
sein am ende waren es viel weniger
unterdessen für putin seinen krieg in
der ost ukraine weiter unerbittlich wie
hier in charkiw
ich bin hier geboren es ist eine
katastrophe ich finde keine worte ich
weiß nicht weiter das hier ist doch mein
ganzes leben
schwere gefechte gibt es seit gestern
auch in anderen städten zum beispiel in
maria k topas maske und kriminal und
wie jeden tag veröffentlicht das
russische verteidigungsministerium auch
heute bilder vom kriegsgeschehen und
lässt die welt wissen man habe
1053 militärobjekte in der ukraine
erfolgreich angegriffen überprüfbar sind
diese angaben nicht
und so zeigt sich vladimir putin auch
entsprechend optimistisch bei einer
veranstaltung mit russischen bürgern
ehrenamtlichen sie trägt den namen
russland das land der möglichkeiten die
so genannte russische militär operation
verspricht putin dann auch wird zu einem
guten ende kommen
ich habe es von anfang an gesagt das
ziel dieser operation ist unseren leuten
zu helfen im don was ein normales und
besseres leben zu leben
wir werden das konsequent zu ende führen
in kiew tragen sie heute ihre liebsten
zu grabe es sind ukrainische soldaten
gestorben im krieg
nun trauern sie an ihren särgen
[Musik]
damit sich die ukraine gegen die
russischen angreifer zur wehr setzen
kann haben mehrere nato länder jetzt
weitere waffenlieferungen angekündigt
teils auch von schwerem gerät die usa
großbritannien die niederlande
deutschland wird selbst keine schweren
waffen liefern stemmt sich aber nicht
dagegen ein regierungssprecher machte
nochmals deutlich man sei eingebunden in
die international abgestimmten
lieferungen dass deutschland seinen
anteil leisten werde versicherte auch
die außenministerin annalena baerbock
heute auf ihrer reise ins baltikum
dennoch hält die diskussionen um
deutsche waffenlieferungen an andreas
künast
die ukraine tanzt sie lebt und sie will
am leben bleiben im friedrichstadtpalast
bitten am abend politiker tänzer
künstler einmal mehr um hilfe damit ihr
land ihre kultur nicht verstummt
am mittag waren die limousinen des
ukrainischen botschafters ins willy
brandt haus gerollt aussprache zwischen
dem entschiedensten antreiber der
deutschen politik und der partei die
manic für die entschiedensten bremse
hält die spd versucht nicht beleidigt zu
wirken aber fraktionschef mütze nicht
beklagt in einem schreiben an die partei
dass kritiker tatsachen teils
unterschlagen teils bewusst falsch
darstellen sagen sie uns was bei dem
treffen rausgekommen ist nein sagt
saskia esken und flitzt an den kameras
vorbei die antwort der ampelkoalition
bleibt im dunkeln aber die frage von
herrn melnik ist bekannt sie betrifft
vor allem ein modell das die bundeswehr
gern benutzt und gern vor zeigt der
märkte kann zwei meter fünfzig breite
gräben und in der messe bis zu ein meter
höhe überwinden gewässer von 1 meter 50
tiefe durchfahren und besitzt eine
steigfähigkeit von 60 prozent
380 mache da hat die bundeswehr und sie
kann so lässt sie wissen keine abgeben
weil ein drittel nicht einsatzbereit ist
und der rest nicht entbehrlich wir
brauchen auch die mader als
hauptwaffensysteme der bundeswehr um
unsere landes und bündnisverteidigung
und unseren bündnisverpflichtungen
sowohl in den einsätzen vor ort an der
ostflanke der nato als auch in der
dahinter stehenden ausbildung ausrüstung
und logistik wahrzunehmen ist
deutschland zu zögerlich gibt das größte
land der eu was es kann in riga trifft
aussenministerin berbalk am nachmittag
die kollegen aus den baltischen staaten
kritik wird nicht laut gemessen am
bruttoinlandsprodukt leistet estland mit
abstand die gewaltigste hilfe dann kommt
litauen dann deutschland dann lettland
es wird immer die frage geben ob man
nicht noch mehr machen kann und
natürlich müssen alle regierungen noch
mehr versuchen
sagen das ist auch für uns kein tabu
aber so sehr sich deutschland bemüht es
hakt zwischen berlin und kiew es hakt
gewaltig dass die ukraine um marder
bittet ist seit wochen öffentlich
bekannt aber das
verteidigungsministerium lässt heute
wissen dass mir keine
anzeigen einzelner malaga sollte ohne
krise vorliegen das ist eine
scheindiskussion stimmt ist dass keine
bedarfs- anzeigen für maria vorliegen
es gibt noch klärungsbedarf zwischen der
ukraine und deutschland aber es gibt
nirgendwo zweifel dass die ukraine lebt
und dass sie weiterleben muss
[Musik]
bei ihrem besuch im baltikum kritisierte
die deutsche außenministerin
ausdrücklich das festhalten der früheren
regierung am bau der deutsch russischen
gaspipeline nord stream 2 das war kritik
an angela merkel aber ließ aufhorchen
denn es ist auch kritik an der früheren
energiepolitik des regierungspartners
spd die tut sich mich leicht mit der
aufarbeitung ihrer verantwortung bei
diesem einstigen prestige projekt unter
druck steht vor allem die spd
ministerpräsidentin von mecklenburg
vorpommern die die gaspipeline vehement
verteidigt hatte heute äußerte sich
manuela schwesig gegenüber dem zdf zu
den vorwürfen bernd mosebach aus
schwerin
irgendwo hinterm horizont auf dem grund
der ostsee liegt sie die pipeline im
hafen von wo kran auf rügen liegt ein
versorgungsschiff dass bei der
vollendung von nord stream zwei gute
dienste geleistet hat die bluechip
mutmaßlich gekauft und betrieben von der
stiftung klima und umweltschutz
mutmaßlich denn die stiftung zeichnete
bisher vor allem eines aus
geheimniskrämerei transparenz sind nur
ihre ziele umwelt projekte fördern und
vor allem nord stream zwei vollenden
doch was genau hat die stiftung getan
rühren gekauft maschinen geliefert
personal gestellt woher kam das geld wie
viele millionen waren es etwas licht ins
dunkel zumindest für die gründungsphase
bringen diese dokumente die die
staatskanzlei auf öffentlichen druck
jetzt veröffentlichen musste klar wird
die landesregierung hat die
stiftungsidee energisch vorangetrieben
doch welchen einfluss hatte nord stream
2 haben die russen etwa schwesig die
satzung diktiert sagen kritiker
es ist normal dass man wenn man einen
solchen infrastruktur projekt arbeitet
dann auch mit dem unternehmen spricht
und vor allem auf die interessen des
landes schaut es ging um arbeitsplätze
im unternehmen
es ging auch um die sanktion umgehung
der us-sanktionen das war das ziel aller
parteien im landtag das war auch weit
verbreitete stimmung im land doch war
diese stiftung der richtige weg schwesig
hat sie mittlerweile als fehler
bezeichnet nord stream 2 ebenso der
opposition reicht das nicht wie ist es
zu dieser klima stiftungsgründung die ja
keine klimastiftung ist gekommen
offensichtlich das zeigen jetzt die
ersten details gab es fahrlässigkeit bei
der entstehungsgeschichte der stiftung
das ist alles sehr mit der heißen nadel
gestrickt und da gibt es auch rechtlich
steuerrecht ich sehr viele fragen die
offen sind noch weitere
zutage treten die vielleicht noch mehr
verstrickungen und vor allen dingen mit
fragwürdige verstärkungen zu tage
fördern dann wäre glaube ich ein thema
wir müssten eigentlich die gesamten
deutsch russischen geschäfte der letzten
jahre von schröder über sigmar gabriel
steinmeier merkel haltmayer aller waren
wollten hier und da ist das sollten
spitze des eisbergs politisch ist die
stiftung bereits tot ihr ende wollen
jetzt alle parteien vor einem jahr
standen noch spd cdu und linke hinter
ihr wenn jetzt einige sich nicht mehr
daran erinnern dass sie das selber
mitgestimmt haben oder dass sie darüber
berichtet haben oder sich vielleicht
auch einige bisher nicht dafür
interessiert haben dann müssen
diejenigen das beantworten wir
jedenfalls haben dem landtag die satzung
mit den zielen transparent vorgelegt am
18 dritter landtag zusammen wichtigster
tagesordnungspunkt einsetzung eines
untersuchungsausschusses so schnell wird
schwerin und wird auch manuela schwesig
das thema nicht los und wir werden
weiter berichten auch bei unserem
nächsten thema geht es um verantwortung
die will die parteivorsitzende der
linken susanne hennig welt so nicht mehr
tragen sie schmiss heute hin
offensichtlich so frustriert wie ratlos
ob der tiefen krise in der ihre partei
steckt ein miserables ergebnis bei der
bundestagswahl
zerstritten bei vielen unter anderem
beim umgang mit russland und dann noch
ein sexismus skandal im hessischen
landesverband der allerdings eher die ko
vorsitzende janine wissler berührte auch
ihr schicksal steht jetzt in den sternen
andrea maurer über eine partei am
abgrund
seit februar 21 war sie zusammen mit
janine wissler parteichefin der linken
heute um 1330 schmeißt susanne hennig
welt so hin sie nennt persönliche gründe
aber auch die jüngsten sexismus vorwürfe
in der partei der umgang mit sexismus in
den eigenen reihen hat eklatante
defizite unserer partei offen gelegt ich
entschuldige mich bei den betroffenen
und unterstütze alle anstrengungen die
jetzt nötig sind um aus der linken eine
partei zu machen in der sexismus keinen
platz hat unter dem hashtag linke mito
sammeln sich seit tagen wut und vorwürfe
sexismus sexueller missbrauch
machtmissbrauch mehr als 60 personen
sollen sich inzwischen beim linken
jugendverband gemeldet haben der will
nun nicht länger schweigen weil es
erstens langsam offen wird dass es ein
netz aus dass das bundesweite es melden
sich aus dem ganzen bundesgebiet leute
bei uns bei der linksjugend
gleichzeitig haben wir aber auch von
anderen leuten vorher schon sehr sehr
viele informationen bekommen und waren
dann ungläubig wollten das
innerparteilich klären am karfreitag
macht der spiegel fälle aus dem
landesverband hessen öffentlich mehr als
zehn jahre war janine wissler dort
fraktionschefin die anschuldigungen
richten sich auch gegen ihren ehemaligen
lebensgefährten einen mitarbeiter der
fraktion hier verpixelt links im bild
verhältnis mit einer anfangs
minderjährigen sexuelle nötigung in
einem statement erklärt wissler ich
weise die unterstellung ich hätte
bereits vor november 21 beziehungsweise
dem jahreswechsel 21 22 kenntnis über
vorwürfe von sexueller belästigung und
machtmissbrauch gehabt entschieden
zurück ich bin sofort tätig geworden als
ich davon erfahren habe
14 monate ist es her dass hennig welt so
und wisla parteichefin wurden was folgte
nennt hennig welt so die schwierigste
phase in der geschichte unserer partei
richtungsstreit wahl-debakel jetzt mit
vorwürfe partei und fraktion sind von
ihrem rücktritt dennoch überrumpelt ja
wir haben eine zugespitzte situation ich
weiß dass der parteivorstand heute abend
tagt um schlussfolgerungen aus der
gesamtsituation auch den mito vorwürfen
zu ziehen aber dass susanne henning welt
sodann heute diesen schritt gegangen ist
war für mich eine überraschung melanie w
regimes landesvorsitzender in rheinland
pfalz und mitglied im bundesvorstand
fordert nach hennig wels rücktritt
weitere konsequenzen meines erachtens
nach muss die ganze partei da
konsequenzen treffen das heißt wir
müssen das debattieren wir müssen
ehrlich zueinander sein und meiner
meinung nach müsste der ganze partei
vorstand neu gewählt werden auch janine
wissler wird es schwer haben sich an der
parteispitze zu halten seit drei stunden
bereit der parteivorstand in einer
digitalen sondersitzung den linken droht
ein führungskampf
ja und da fragen wir nach bei theo koll
in berlin gehören der parteivorstand hat
heute abend getagt oder es immer noch
dabei was hören sie welche konsequenzen
zieht die partei jetzt in dieser
situation nun gehören bisher aus der
noch laufenden sitzung des beschlüsse
zur neuwahl des vorstands erst am
wochenende getroffen werden sollen der
fraktionsvorsitzende der linkspartei
bartsch hatte am rande der sitzung heute
gesagt dass die noch verbleibende
parteivorsitzende wissler in parteitag
im juni vorbereiten sollen das klingt
zumindest nach einer wenn auch
übersichtlichen zeitlichen perspektive
für diese übrig gebliebene parteispitze
und der linken- geschäftsführer hat
angekündigt er werde vorschlagen im juni
den gesamten vorstand neu wählen zu
lassen beides klingt danach dass man
zeit gewinnen will um sich vielleicht zu
sortieren denn der heutige rücktritt kam
mir für alle überraschend selbst die
partei pressestelle erfurts zeitgleich
mit uns medien die linkspartei das war
ja auch mal ein großes anti projekt des
einstigen spd granden oskar lafontaine
jetzt riecht das irgendwie nach sichtung
da scheint eine partei geradezu in
abwicklung kann sie das noch stoppen
also es gibt eine kleine lebensweisheit
von walter jens die ich erinnere auf dem
weg zum abgrund hat er gesagt kann eine
panne lebensrettend sein wir sagen
parteien haben ja gerne mal ein längeres
leben als es in den zeiten großer krisen
erscheint aber die lage der linkspartei
ist schon sehr nah am abgrund in ihrer
einstigen hochburg
saarland kam sie ja noch auf 2,6 prozent
bei der bundestagswahl scheiterte sie an
der fünf prozent hürde kommen dann nur
dank dreier direktmandate wieder in den
bundestag die parteiinternen querelen
der ungelöste richtungsstreit der
brutale ukraine kriegt der ja auf eine
traditionelle russland freundliche
partei trifft die eigentlich ja die
auflösung der nato fordert also es
scheint dass die partei selbst nicht
mehr weiß wofür sie eigentlich stehen
soll und die missbrauchsvorwürfe einer
ja eigentlich sich feministisch
verstehen partei die kommen hier noch
oben drauf also ich glaube es wird mehr
brauchen als nur neue gesichter die
analyse von theo koll vielen dank nach
berlin
und in den nachrichten kern wir noch mal
zurück in die ukraine
bundesratspräsident michelle war
überraschend zu gesprächen mit präsident
selensky in kiew dabei kündigte mitchell
an die eu werde der ukraine weitere 1,5
milliarden euro an militärhilfe zukommen
lassen zielinski und michelle berieten
auch über bedingungen für einen beitritt
der ukraine zur eu sowie über den in
brüssel eingereichten fragebogen der
ukraine das papier gilt als grundlage
für beitrittsgespräche die türkische
offensive gegen die verbotene kurdische
arbeiterpartei pkk im nordirak dauert an
über opfer ist bislang nichts bekannt
präsident erdogan drohte heute so
wörtlich die köpfe der
terror-organisation auch in syrien zu
zermalmen
er hoffe dass es den ort des
hauptquartiers der pkk bald nicht mehr
geben werde seit montag attackiert die
türkische armee kurdische kämpfer im
nordirak aus der luft und am boden in
shanghai wurde der strikte corona
lockdown für weitere vier millionen
menschen gelockert ende märz hatten die
behörden alle 26 millionen einwohner
angewiesen zu hause zu bleiben
noch immer ist rund die hälfte davon
betroffen viele kommen nicht an
lebensmittel und medikamente laut
behörden sind in shanghai nur 17
menschen an dem virus verstorben eine
zahl die international angezweifelt wird
in der korona pandemie hat sich der
antisemitismus in deutschland verstärkt
das bundesamt für verfassungsschutz
berichtet durch die pandemie seien
jahrhundertealte
verschwörungsvorstellungen neu
verbreitet worden und reichten bis in
die mitte der gesellschaft
bundesinnenministerium faeser sagte es
sei eine schande wie viel
menschenverachtung auch heute verbreitet
würde jüdinnen und juden in deutschland
versprach sie schutz
mutmaßlich ein sogenannter reichs bürger
hat im baden-württembergischen boxberg
einen polizeibeamten angeschossen und
leicht verletzt bei einem sek-einsatz
sollte das haus des mutmaßlichen täters
durchsucht werden wegen des verdacht des
illegalen waffenbesitzes sieben personen
wurden festgenommen
aus ungeklärter ursache geriet das haus
in brand die polizei sieht hinweise auf
verbindungen zur szene der reichs bürger
die die existenz der bundesrepublik
deutschland leugnet er
gegen sie so heißt es heute abend in
frankreich präsident gegen
herausforderin mitte gegen rechts europa
freund gegen nationalistin fünf tage vor
der stichwahl um die präsidentschaft
liefern sich im manual makro und marine
le pen das einzige fernsehduell das
rennen ist eng und es steht viel auf dem
spiel das duell läuft seit 21 uhren und
thomas walde beobachtet es für uns nicht
allein sondern in einer kneipe am
pariser gare du nord thomas nach gut
einer stunde
wie schlagen sich die beiden zeichnet
sich ein sieger ab gab es schon
auffälligkeiten besonderheiten
also es gab bislang zwei themen die
hauptsächlich besprochen wurden und das
sind auch die themen die im wahlkampf
sehr häufig besprochen wurden das erste
thema war kauf kamen es ging darum wer
will was unternehmen damit die menschen
in frankreich besser mit der inflation
klarkommen dass wir im grunde ein
finanzpolitisches ein austausch
finanzpolitischer details der schwer 40
aber nachzuvollziehen war werde am ende
mehr macht lebendiger wurde ist
tatsächlich in der letzten viertelstunde
als viel über internationale politik
geredet wurde das kann man also
offensichtlich auch im wald machen das
deutsch französische verhältnis wurde
gesprochen und die bedeutung europas in
die beiden haben sehr unterschiedliche
positionen dazu gehabt hier sind
hauptsächlich mal
gucken ob wir jemanden finden der
deutsch sprechend ist uns nicht gelungen
ich frage mal hier bei einer
französischen
krieges
nach guten atmosphäre hier
kandidaten und er wird es bis zum
schluss machen
vor fünf jahren gab es ja das gleiche
duell ist das dann mal für sich
entschied ziemlich klar sogar wird der
ausgang dieses duells heute eigentlich
die wahl mit entscheiden oder wie stark
mit entscheiden
also es gibt dort umfrage tatsächlich
noch sehr viele wählerinnen und wähler
die im ersten wahlgang links gestimmt
haben noch nicht wissen gewinnen sie
sich im zweiten wahlgang in der
stichwahl entscheiden sollen weil sie
sowohl mit makro und auch mittelmann
eigentlich wenig anfangen können und
beim letzten mal vor fünf jahren
enttäuscht waren dann doch am ende firma
core gestimmt zu haben und der immer
mehr nach rechts gerückt weil sie mit
dessen politik nicht einverstanden sind
da können also solche diskussionen wie
heute abend diese einzige tv debatten
kann da bei diesen wählerinnen und
wieder vielleicht etwas bewirken und das
kann da die umfragen doch recht knapp
sich insgesamt noch einen ausschlag habe
ich noch ein kurzer ausblick sollte le
pen das rennen machen kommen ja auf
europa wirklich veränderte harte zeiten
zu sie definiert ja auch das verhältnis
zu russland deutlich anders wann sie
eine prognose wie es ausgeht sonntag
also in den umfang richtmikrofon und die
umfrage entwickeln sich derzeit für ihn
man merkt doch im land viele
organisationen haben dazu aufgerufen die
rechtsakte kandidatin extremen rechten
zu verhindern gewerkschaften künstler
und andere es gibt schon zu einem
kleinen schub in seiner richtung so dass
man davon ausgehen könnte dass er das
buch knapp gewinnt aber gemessen an dem
was da auf dem spiel steht für europa
das deutsch französische verhältnis und
ähnliches treffen hat deutschland sehr
heftig kritisiert in diesem wahlkampf
ist das doch zu knapp und ist diese
aussicht doch zu schwach und sich nach
schon beruhigt zurückzulehnen
dankeschön thomas walde nach paris so
nun noch einmal nachrichten die mit den
wirtschaftlichen folgen des kriegs
beginnen das thema bei der
frühjahrstagung des internationalen
währungsfonds kunde heute nahmen auch
die finanzminister der g20 staaten an
den beratungen von iwf und weltbank teil
finanzminister lindner machte dabei
russland allein verantwortlich für die
gegenwärtigen weltweiten ökonomischen
probleme als der russische
finanzminister das wort ergreifen wollte
kam es gerade eben wohl zu einer
vereinbarten demonstration mehrerer
minister aus washington benjamin daniel
als sich russland beim g20-treffen zu
wort meldet verlässt diese gruppe
demonstrativ den raum mit dabei unter
anderem die us finanzministerium die
aktion zeigt unter welch schwierigen
bedingungen der heutige tag stattfindet
für den deutschen finanzminister begann
er mit einem pressefrühstück und vielen
schwer zu beantwortenden fragen zur
zukunft der weltwirtschaft ich glaube
wir sind in einer situation wo wochen
dekaden prägen
wir werden in ganz anderem
geopolitischen und makroökonomischen
umfeldern in den nächsten jahren
arbeiten in amerikas hauptstadt will die
internationale finanz elite lösungen
finden auf die zahlreichen probleme
dieser zeit pandemie krieg inflation
klimawandel all das führt zu düsteren
prognose so rechnet der iwf weltweit nur
noch mit 3,6 prozent wirtschaftswachstum
0,8 weniger als bei der vorherigen
prognose die deutsche wirtschaft soll
nur noch um 2,1 prozent wachsen eine
korrektur um minus 1,7 prozentpunkte
erst die pandemie jetzt der kriegt wir
werden von einem sturm heimgesucht bevor
wir uns von dem vorigen sturm erholen
konnten das resultat ist ein massiver
einbruch der weltwirtschaft
verantwortlich dafür sind hauptsächlich
die russische invasion der ukraine und
die schockwellen die das rund um den
globus verursacht
selten bekam die turnusmäßige
frühjahrstagung von iwf und weltbank so
viel beachtung selten waren die probleme
die es zu bewältigen gibt vergleichbar
groß
wie zum beispiel die weltweit hohe
inflation und eben zunehmende probleme
auch für die entwicklungsländer valerie
haller ja weil deren volkswirtschaften
nun die gerade erwähnten zwei
schockwellen aushalten müssen nämlich
die panne mit ihrer wirtschaftskrise und
der ukraine krieg der energie und
lebensmittel teurer macht geplant sind
finanzprogramme auch weil man eben eine
globale schuldenkrise verhindern möchte
dass auch in deutschland die preise
weiter stark steigen zeigen die
erzeugerpreise sie haben im märz so
stark angezogen wie noch nie fast ein
drittel mussten hersteller im schnitt
mehr bezahlen als noch vergangen das
jahr preistreiber war wieder die energie
strom für gewerbe und industrie wurde um
85 prozent teurer heizöl um 130 prozent
und erdgas sogar um 144 prozent die
preise bei den herstellern gehen durch
die decke mit zeitverzögerung kommt dass
auch beim endverbraucher an entspannung
ist erst mal nicht im sich in sicht im
gegenteil viele volkswirte glauben das
ende der fahnenstange ist noch nicht
erreicht
vielen dank valerie nach frankfurt die
neuauflage der staatlichen förderung für
energieeffizientes bauen ist nach
wenigen stunden wieder gestoppt worden
das zusätzlich bereitgestellte geld eine
milliarde euro ist laut
bundeswirtschaftsministerium bereits
ausgeschöpft die zuständige kfw
besteuerung keine anträge mehr zu
stellen schon im januar musste die
staatliche förderung für nachhaltiges
bauen abrupt eingestellt werden die
mittel waren ausgeschöpft im kommenden
jahr soll es ein neues programm geben
fehlen noch die gewinnzahlen vom lotto
am mittwoch sie lauten ohne gewähr 10 16
19 20 35 44 superzahl 3 weitere
gewinnzahlen auf lotto zdf de und im zdf
text
ja damit sind wir am ende aber das
auslandsjournal beginnt und das sollten
sie nicht verpassen antje pieper war in
polen und hat dort ukrainische
flüchtlinge getroffen unbedingt dran
bleiben und
um 0.30 ist hier wieder zeit für unser
heute schon mal update mit nasa
optimieren tschüss bis morgen
[Musik]
guten abend spiel heißt das hoch hier
über skandinavien und die tiefs renate
simone und talk für uns interessant ist
jetzt erstmal noch das tief renate das
bringt nämlich volk mit und kühle luft
aber zum ende der woche wird immer mehr
tief simone spannend für uns denn das
bringt von südwesten eher wechselhaftes
wetter heute nacht ist es meist stark
bewölkt hier in der nordhälfte und das
kann richtung sachsen auch noch ein
bisschen regnen im süden ist es dagegen
klar und so sinken die temperaturen dort
bis minus 1 grad am alpenrand milder
bleibt es zum beispiel in der lausitz
mit 6 grad die höchsttemperaturen morgen
liegen zwischen 10 grad zum beispiel
hier in thüringen und 20 grad am
oberrhein und morgen ist das wetter ganz
unterschiedlich wir haben zum teil
strahlenden sonnenschein zum beispiel
schleswig holstein oder auch zwischen
der mosel und am alpenrand hier im
nordosten dagegen bleibt es trüb es kann
auch ein bisschen tröpfeln da haben sie
mit etwas glück vielleicht drei oder
vier sonnenstunden ganz anders sieht es
hier richtung süden aus da gibt es das
astronomische mögliche 14 sonnenstunden
zum beispiel an der donau an der isar
aber auch an der kieler bucht oder in
der lübecker bucht auf weiter ziehen
einige dichtere wolkenfelder noch über
norddeutschland sonst wird das ein
freundlicher und trockener tag dann aber
wird es von südwesten deutlich
wechselhafter es kommen regenschauer und
gewitter und die breiten sich am sonntag
weiter richtung norden und osten aus
guten abend